- [Voiceover] And now, True
Love Stories from women
just like you.
- I met Stephen at a Barnes and Nobles
which seems retro I know.
But I was like carrying
this big stack of books
and he bumped into me like we were in
some sort of romantic comedy and the books
spill everywhere and he
helps me pick them up
and I just knew.
- How I met Richard?
My sister set us up.
She knows me so well and
you know, she was right.
Richard knew me well too.
It was actually a perfect match.
- I met Mike when I was
walking down the street
and he went,
"Yo that ass is fat."
and I was like,
"This ass?" and he was like, "That ass."
and I walked back toward him and
he asked me to put my number in his phone
immediately so I did.
It was beautiful.
- [Voiceover] What was
your first date like?
- It was actually hard to
schedule our first date
because Stephen's a doctor, a surgeon.
So I surprised him at
the hospital for lunch
and I just couldn't
let him go back to work
because he was too great to let get away.
- He came over and he cooked
my sister and I dinner.
Duck, for three people,
it was very hard to do.
And it was delicious
and I couldn't imagine
a more romantic night.
- On our first date we
just got in the back
seat of Mike's Honda and just got it in.
Like, we just got it in all night.
Until the cops came and
moved us from the park.
To which Mike yelled,
"(bleeped) the Police!"
and we just ran and ran.
It was adorable.
- [Voiceover] What's the sweetest
thing he ever said to you?
- The sweetest thing that
Stephen ever said to me
is that when he first
saw me he never expected
to see me every day for
the rest of his life.
But here I am!
- He didn't actually say it to me
he said it about me
to my sister, I overheard,
he said that I was
the nicest girl he has ever met.
I'm sorry, I just got choked up.
- The sweetest thing
Mike ever said to me was,
" I wanna (bleeped) you so hard that you
"(bleeped) scream and
I just want to take my
"(bleeped) and put it in
your (bleeped) and out of it,
"in your (bleeped) and out of it,
"in your (bleeped) and out of it
"and I wanna (long bleep)
and (bleeped) and I love you."
- That's not a true love
story that's disgusting.
- I'm so sorry, are you okay?
That is disrespectful.
- No it's not, it's how we fell in love.
- Why is she even here? That's horrible!
- They asked for true love stories.
- That is gross.
- It's how I found love!
- You don't need to be
talked to like that.
- I'm uncomfortable.
- I'm fine it's how we...
- [Voiceover] Ladies, ladies calm down.
Everyone deserves to be here.
So let's talk about marriage.
- Oh well Stephen and I haven't actually
tied the knot yet because there was
a series of miscommunications.
He thinks I'm a stalker but...
(laughs)
you can't stalk something
that belongs to you!
You know? (laughs)
It doesn't make any sense.
He'll come around.
- It actually didn't work
out for me and Richard.
He ended up marrying my sister,
which is fine because I'm an aunt now.
So...
- Well Mike and I have
been married for 10 years
have two kids and a house
on the country side.
Oh, this is him calling me now.
Hey Mike!
Did you get the milk honey?
(laughing)
No I'm just sitting here
with some lonely ass bitches
shooting a special or something like that.
Yeah, I don't know, one's a psycho
and the other one slept with her sister.
- I didn't sleep with my sister.
- It was just a miscommunication.
Are any of you,
are any of you guys like available?
To like get coffee after this? Or...
- Can I go?
- [Voiceover] And this has
been True Love Stories.